"A Quiet Place Part II" picks up right where the
first leaves off. With their farmhouse in ruins,
the surviving Abbotts head out into the wider
world, discovering that not everyone has taken to
the apocalypse as gracefully as they have. Let's
break down the ending of "A Quiet Place Part II."
Writer, director, and star John Krasinski
calls the "Quiet Place" films a love
letter to his children, and when "A Quiet
Place Part II" ends, it's easy to see why.
While the first movie is all about
the sacrifices parents make to keep
their children safe, the second sees the
Abbott kids step up and become the heroes,
with both Regan and Marcus
managing to defeat a Death Angel.
In both cases, the kids are
protecting the adults around them,
reversing the roles of the previous film
when they needed their parents' protection.
Both of their victories also show
how their experiences in the harsh,
post-apocalyptic world have changed
them, and not necessarily for the better.
Most importantly, though, these are two
moments of huge personal growth. For Marcus,
who is somehow even more anxious in "A Quiet
Place Part II" than he was in the first movie,
his killing of a Death Angel is when he finally
overcomes his fears and stands up for himself.
For Regan, it marks the end of her quest.
She's done her part to save the world,
honoring her father's memory in the process.
The most important character in "A Quiet
Place Part II" may be one who's already dead.
Lee Abbott, played by Krasinski,
sacrificed himself in order to
save his family in the first movie, and
his legacy looms large over the sequel.
Lee taught Marcus the skills the boy uses to
survive the movie's climax. Regan embarked on
her journey to find the radio tower because,
as she says, it's what Lee would've done.
That's why the opening flashback in "A Quiet
Place Part II" is more than an excuse to give
Krasinski some screen time. Sure, it's fun to
see how everything started, and the opening
invasion is full of exciting set pieces. It's not
just fan service, though. Lee is central to both
Regan and Marcus' arcs, so having him appear in
the beginning makes the ending hit a lot harder.
While the first movie showed that Lee
could be obsessive and hard-headed,
his portrayal in "Part II" is overwhelmingly
positive. He's a good father, a nice neighbor,
and a well-liked member of the community. Showing
up late to a Little League game seems to be his
only flaw. In this case, that's okay. This time,
Regan, Marcus, and Evelyn are dealing with Lee's
memory, not the actual man. It only makes sense
that we see an idealized version of him, too.
Lee is also central to the story of Emmett,
the Abbotts' former neighbor who has holed
up in the old steel mill. Emmett is everything
that Lee isn't. Instead of sacrificing himself
to save his family, Emmett watched his wife
and children die. While the Abbotts tried
to make life on the farm feel as normal as
possible, Emmett trades comfort for survival.
Lee sought out other survivors. Emmett argues
that anyone who's still alive isn't to be trusted.
"I don't know why you came all the
way up here. There's nothing left."
The contrast between Lee and Emmett
becomes even more pronounced when
Emmett reluctantly agrees to accompany
Regan on her trip to the radio tower,
essentially becoming a surrogate
father figure to the young girl.
Despite his gruff and at times paranoid exterior,
Emmett is a good man, and the journey changes him.
He forges a real bond with Regan, even using
the limited amount of sign language he knows to
protect her from danger. Once he and Regan
reach the island, Emmett discovers that,
much to his surprise, good people can still
thrive in this world. When the monster attacks,
Emmett pulls moves straight from Lee's playbook,
putting himself in harm's way to save others.
He draws the monster's attention away
from the community by driving the truck,
then puts himself in harm's way to
protect Regan at the radio station.
Emmett will never take Lee's
place, but by the end of the film,
he's beginning to follow his old friend's
example — and the world is better off for it.
"A Quiet Place Part II" expands on the
world of the first movie by explaining
the monsters' origins -- yes, they're
from space -- and also showing how
different communities have reacted to
the apocalypse beyond the Abbotts' farm.
"It's such an inspired sequel. The world expands
in this one because they have to venture out."
For Krasinski, who wrote the screenplay
for "A Quiet Place Part II" on his own,
this presents a conundrum. Despite the
wide-open corn fields and airy feel of the
Abbotts' homestead, the first "Quiet Place"
movie really takes after films like "Alien"
and John Carpenter's "The Thing," which trap
their heroes in a confined space with a deadly,
paranoia-inducing monster. Going outside
the farm threatens to upend that balance,
robbing the sequel of everything
that makes the franchise special.
Krasinski's solution to this problem is
clever. While the world gets larger in "A
Quiet Place Part II," the action itself
moves into increasingly small spaces.
The opening flashback consumes an entire
town. The first steps in the Abbots'
journey take them into the wilderness.
From there, they move to the steel mill,
and then a small bunker inside. By the time
Marcus and Evelyn reach the movie's climax,
they're trapped in a cramped vault. Similarly,
Regan and Emmett go from upstate New York to a
remote, isolated island, and end up making
their final stand in a tiny radio station.
In this way, Krasinksi ratchets up the
claustrophobic tension that defined
the first movie, even while broadening
the series' mythology at the same time.
"A Quiet Place Part II" plays on the confined
atmosphere of the first movie in another way, too.
In "Part II," all of the characters are trapped
— sometimes literally. Marcus steps on an actual
bear trap. Emmett has a rope tied around his neck,
restricting his movement. Regan ends up cornered
in an old train. An entire community is stuck
on an island with nowhere to run when a monster
attacks, baby Abbott is kept in a box, and Marcus
locks himself in the vault under the steel plant.
But the characters are mentally trapped,
too. Marcus is dominated by his fear.
Emmett is haunted by his inability to save
his family. Regan's sense of obligation,
and the example set by her father, can't
be escaped. Evelyn isn't exactly shackled
to her family, but as the one who ensures
their survival, she's forced to undertake
some risky missions, at least until the
kids prove they can protect themselves.
In that light, Regan's quest takes on a different
connotation. Killing the monsters isn't the goal,
it's a means to an end. Regan's real mission
revolves around freedom: the freedom to live a
normal life, and to escape the terror that's
plagued them since the alien attack began.
"A Quiet Place Part II" ends on an image of
hope: Regan's implant, dangling from the radio
station microphone, its disruptive signal being
broadcast to people all over America's east coast.
And yet, while this is clearly supposed
to be a sign of positive things to come,
"A Quiet Place Part II" proves time
and again that safety is an illusion.
And that's without taking into account
the problems with Regan's plan.
Are people really going to be listening
to the radio without headphones in a
world where sound attracts monsters?
If not, how will they ever realize that
the random screeching coming over the
airwaves is the key to their survival?
These are real questions, but to be fair,
neither "Quiet Place" movie is
perfect when it comes to plot logic.
While "A Quiet Place Part II" greatly expands our
understanding of the post-apocalyptic world, there
are a number of questions that remain when the
credits begin. Narratively, it's probably for the
best that these movies don't delve into the larger
socio-political implications of the invasion, but
there are still things we want to know about our
characters that the film simply doesn't answer.
Mainly, what do Regan and Emmett do now? Do they
return to the steel plant and reunite with the
rest of the Abbott family, or do they wait for
Evelyn, Marcus, and the baby to come to them?
What is the state of the island community, now
that it has been attacked by a monster, and
many of its residents are dead? Will life continue
there like it did before, or is that refuge gone?
As mentioned before, it's also not clear
exactly how Regan's plan is going to pan out,
either. It feels like there are a few more steps
that need to be taken before the monsters are
in real trouble. Finally, after two movies,
are we ever going to learn that baby's name?
If "A Quiet Place Part II" performs well at the
box office, a sequel seems almost guaranteed.
What's less obvious is whether or not the
Abbotts will return. On top of the husband
and wife team at the head of the series maybe
being ready to move on, it kind of feels like
the Abbotts' story is over. It's not clear
how much room for growth they have left.
The alien invasion was a global event, though,
and there are plenty of other locations where
people are probably still struggling to survive.
What do things look like in different climates,
or other countries? And what would this
world look like, years down the line?
Abbotts or no Abbotts, the "Quiet Place" movies
thrive on being stories about everyday people.
Stick to that core, and the franchise
could run for a very long time.
Check out one of our newest videos right
here! Plus, even more Looper videos
about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.